something beautiful about
martial arts like exactly as you said is
the coach
like in wrestling and at least
collegiate like high level wrestling
it's like there's a dictatorship aspect
to a coach
that is very important to have like
this this ridiculous sometimes nature of
like master and so on and bowing all
these traditions there's something
it seems ridiculous from the outside
perhaps but there's something really
powerful to that
because that process of you said why not
of letting go of the leap of faith
requires you to believe that the coach
has your best
interest in mind and just give yourself
over to
their ideas of how
how you should grow and that's an
interesting thing i mean i've never been
able to
really see coaches i've had as
human they're always you always it's
like a father figure or
like this you always put them in this
position of power and i think that's
i think at least at least for me it's
been a very
it's been a very useful way to see the
coach because it allows you to not
think and let go and really allow
yourself to grow
and emotionally deal with all the
beatings they'll push you where past
oftentimes where you would have stopped
yourself right which is great and
hopefully they know
they if they're paying attention and
they're they're still a person they can
make mistakes but they'll push you
further than you would have gone
but not so far that it's not
facilitative right right that's
something that i can
say like for as a hobby um the head
coach of tristar my head coach for mma
kenny florian one of the head coaches
for mma
have both been phenomenal influences
paul schreiner who's the uh
one of the assistants at marcella
garcia's academy um coached me in jiu
jitsu for a long time brilliant
instructor
they've all been able to do that and i
think what's interesting about all of
those guys they're very sharp but they
they're very intuitive as well and i
think that for us actually uh you know
told me about something that john wooden
said
john wooden the legendary ucla
basketball coach
just a simple philosophical idea just he
said some people's life
is a bowl of it needs some whipped
cream in it some people's life is a bowl
of whipped cream
needs a little bit of in it just to
balance it out and it's an interesting
thing coaching everyone the same way
doesn't work you know that's i think the
difference between a coach and an
instructor and a lot of times people
think they want to coach but they really
want an instructor i'm like hey lex tell
me what to do not how to do it
and then other times people think they
want you know an instructor and they
really want to coach
i'm like man this guy's just giving me
information a coach is so much more than
an instructor and that's a huge leap
and that's something that i think that
people need to understand when they're
going into martial arts and i understand
i can totally grasp why they don't
because how how would they know
but uh i think about this a lot like me
giving you 150
for a month which is not nothing that's
for sure that does not that pays for
instructor really
coach is a relationship that gets
developed because you can imagine like
just the amount of
emotional investment and and time
thinking away from from like oh alex
isn't here anymore what can i do to help
him what does he need
like that's that's serious and that's
the difference between that's that's
oftentimes the difference that at
getting getting over the hump in various
situations so it's a it's an interesting
you know bargain that's being made like
commitment by the by the instructor who
becomes a coach commitment by the
student
you know like there's a financial
transaction there's a lot of things
going on there but i feel very fortunate
to have had
not just instructors in my time but
coaches and that means sometimes we
butted heads
and sometimes i look back and i think i
was right and other times look back on
my own no they were definitely right
but there was always the trust um with
the exception of one time that i feel
that trust was greatly betrayed
that rightly or wrongly whether mistakes
mistakes will be made but
everyone is attempting to do do the
right thing under no circumstances would
i intentionally
do anything malicious you know versus
hey i might have done i'm going to burn
your house down but you can be darn sure
it wasn't on purpose
and i think that as long as there's that
mutual understanding and mutual belief
of goodwill
which again doesn't just magic up out of
nowhere i understand
i think that that's when then great
things can happen and i look at all the
athletes that i know
you know the guys and girls that i've
watched become fantastic in various
places
almost invariably it never happened
alone
you